monsieur raymond barre en visite
officielle en autriche a dit au cours
d'une conférence de presse à vienne la
coopération de la france avec l'irak
n'est pas seulement militaire elle
touche aussi l'industrie la technologie
la culture les deux pays ont toujours eu
des relations confiantes nous n'avons de
leçons à recevoir de personne sur les
livraisons d'armes françaises et je
demande à ceux qui s'intéressent pas la
question de considérer également les
ventes d'armes faites par d'autres tel
est le résumé de ce qu'a dit monsieur
bart maintenant des précisions de vienne
par piranha
ce qui nous paraît essentiel dans cette
affaire c'est que la liberté de
circulation
dans le détroit d'ormuz puisse être
sauvegardés ceci est nécessaire non
seulement à la france mais bien entendu
à l'ensemble des pays européens qui
s'approvisionnent en pétrole auprès des
pays du golfe vous m'avez posé une
question sur les ventes d'armes de la
france agira
je profite de cette question pour
préciser deux points en premier lieu la
coopération de la france avec l'irak
n'est pas seulement une coopération
militaire
elle est une coopération qui se
développe dans tous les domaines
industriel culturel
le domaine de la technologie avancée
nous avons 4500 français qui travaillent
en irak
nous avons toujours eue avec ce pays des
relations politiques confiante l'irak
comme la france sont attachés à leur
indépendance
et le problème
des ventes d'art n'est qu'un problème
tout à fait limité dans l'ensemble de
l'accord et de la coopération irako
française
ma deuxième observation est que je
voudrais une fois pour tout dire à ceux
qui
s'intéressent aux ventes d'armes par la
france de bien vouloir considérer les
ventes d'armes qui sont faites par les
autres pays et je dis de la manière la
plus nette que nous n'entendons cherche
point recevoir de leçons de personne